we're at the Grammy Museum this is
freaking cool I know what's it this is
so intimate it's so amazing you've been
playing these massive like huge can't
even see to the end of it ocean crowds
and now to be here in this intimate
setting sort of on the eve of you know
Grammys this is where we kind of start
rolling for Grammys what does it feel
like to be here you know what's funny is
that I used to come in all the time when
I was younger I want I saw like lots of
shows on this stage in this room so it
was weird so like just now be walking in
and this is the situation you know like
it's super weird because I came here my
entire childhood I saw so many artists
here it was so much fun
it's like a 360 it really is I love that
what is that I can't believe this
happened in my life moment on stage of
the past year I feel like the most
recent one I mean I just was on this
Europe tour where it was just every
single show felt like that I mean we did
this the first show of that tour was
Prague Pops amazing don't quit like just
the most the craziest energy just like
love the whole room was just like well
filled with what was crazy
your brother is here such an important
part of your life I love this photo how
cute is this what what what makes your
relationship and your friendship so
special I mean we've always been close I
don't I mean we don't we don't have any
other siblings so there isn't really
another one we have to get along with or
not get along with but we've we've
always been close I mean I think that I
think was cool is that we have a job
where we're both super in close
corporate close quarters yes yeah and I
think it really brought us together I
think it made our friendship even
stronger and I don't know he's my best
friend so it's like it's just good all
the time it's crazy good to true around
together and you have to collaborate and
the fact that you know your success is
his success and his success is your
success that's like a beautiful thing to
share with it's great you know me and
there's no jealousy because it's like
it's so different for like we want
completely different things but we're
both making it happen
yeah and saying so it's really a journey
pretty much so bad guy obviously reached
number one is that your favorite song
just saying are you
I'm singing it and you're like I have
other songs people or what is your
favorite time to sing live you know
what's funny about that is that I always
like it's because that song has the
recognition that it has and because it's
like the one that people know when they
don't know my music it's funny because I
always see like the the superfriends
gorilla I love till my core they're
always like like you know if you only
know bad guy like you're a fake fan and
then I got all this stuff which I
totally understand because of being a
fan of something like when someone only
likes the big song drives you insane I'm
not tired I'm just starting with that
one so I'm it's every time I do it live
it's so much fun I'm not I have no I'm
not bored of it at all I love it we're
at the Grammy Museum you are in
contention to be nominated up for the
big four awards that the Graham is the
youngest woman ever to do that is that
true that's crazy
I would never have I could have bet you
money that that would never happen
have you thought about like in the
shower sometimes I talk with people and
they're like I've been practicing my
Grammy speech am i America award speech
since I was a kid and I knew that it was
coming now
now that's so ugly that people practice
that the further really people say that
yeah they're like I've been thinking my
award speech my whole life in the car no
okay I still haven't thought about it I
don't think I will be on stage [ __ ] you
know like I don't I think it's so weird
when people think they're gonna be huge
god that's so weird I never in a million
years would've thought this would happen
like I'm only grateful for it for you I
love that everyone wants to know when's
the next album coming or you're like
just art and album out I know but if
this is we live in this world when it's
like next month and you have them uh
when I make it okay happy there have you
and your brother even have you started
thinking about it or is it you're just
living in this right now oh we made I
mean we've been making music on the road
for like the past couple I mean we're
not I think what cool about it right now
is it like on the
just on and which were before that and
stuff like we've just been writing and
not worrying about what it's for just
enjoying your creativity I guess who I
love that okay you're gonna turn 18 in
December will you have a big birthday
party and what will this birthday party
look like and I've been trying to think
of it for months
okay eighteen has been like the age I've
always wanted to be my entire life
yeah there it is yeah I have something
in mind okay but we'll get there okay
Judith is it like a themed is it a
costume are you thinking about moving
out to a new place getting a house with
a big studio or anything like that
you're just sticking at home um I mean
if I am it's for me to know you have a
car but you do not have a driver's
license yes oh oh you don't
who's the internet I don't know you have
are you driving yeah you want to see my
driver's license are you good I have it
right there I'm great what you're great
driver I have an incredible car how's
your parallel park a good my parallel
parking is actually fantastic I'm I'm
good
I'm very good okay I love right I'm very
good I'm what could you everyone in your
teams like yes excellent um what is the
song you like to sing karaoke to if you
like to sing karaoke I don't want to go
ever gotten to karaoke okay okay karaoke
do you sing any songs when you have to
warm up your voice before show um I did
I used to like the first tour I actually
had a song I would warm up with which
was Sabrina Claudia it was um I think it
was unravel me or belong to you I don't
know it was always Sabrina fabulous now
I just do one website you're heading to
SNL I am that's even next level
SNL is an iconic and whole Hollywood
moment I know in a photo shoot you get
to do and you're on that stage we're
like the greats have been yeah are you
nervous what are you bringing on so
excited I'm actually so excited I I feel
like I've TV but TV performances are
like a complete different world yes it's
so tear
and so I mean the experiences I've had
it's always been good so yeah looking
forward to it so there is the what I'm
calling Billie's Hollywood stand Club
which is like all the celebrities that
are like obsessed with you so I just
want to like go through it bring me my
photos Joseph oh you got prepared for
this interview Julia Roberts a doll look
at that look at her just loving on you
look I wish everyone would looked at me
the way Julia Roberts looks at Billy
damn what was what did she say to you in
this moment she said something that was
so good
I remember exactly I don't remember
exactly what she said but I remember in
the moment I was like this lady is a
genius like just so precious she said
something to me that was I really should
try to remember it because I remember it
being very like it made me the man you
think she she was so sweet she just
would look at me I know should we just
grab my doesn't just be like and just
stare at me for real like for like a
while and her sunny times his name the
same as your brother yes she has a
Phineas she has a Phineas
okay I need for mucinous Katy Perry in a
bucket had she posted that she says we
must protect you
beings like her don't enter our orbit
often that's super sweet Katy Perry and
Orlando Bloom just smiling at his little
wifey I know did she give you any advice
for this this world um she just said if
I need anything she's there which I
always really really respect and hard to
see that especially artists that have
been through it especially like as
intensely as she has or someone else so
yeah I love it when you call her Senor
Rita gosh this is like the collab of my
life
I love Camila so much is a perfect nose
she really does is it great nose you
have a great nose too
you guys are really cute together you're
like the same high it's amazing what was
this moment what happened is this is
this the talk of like do you want to
collaborate on a song yeah sure really
no it's not
she just was there and I was and she was
nice gosh okay no no listen no she was
actually it was just it was a shoot we
were doing for Elle magazine we're doing
the cover and she was before me and I
was gonna be after her and we yeah she
just she was there and she was super
cute she was with her little sister and
her sister started sobbing because of me
and it was like insane I was like your
sisters for like the Bayeux though
people love you now this is a crazy
thing people in the world are
speculating that you and demi lovato are
collaborating because you have the same
hair color right now mm-hmm
she does wait can I say I totally
respect her but if she was done the last
thing I would do is collaborate with
someone who has the same hair is no I'm
saying it's too much you can get yeah I
think she's so incredibly talented yeah
but I don't I don't think she has my
hair think y'all are reaching a little
bit there was a photo of you in a ver
Lavigne does that mean you're
collaborating it doesn't unfortunately
but she is incredible she's the queen he
had me come to her rehearsal for her
show that she this is like a tour she's
she's doing since like five years I'm
not swimming which is that I think
that's what it was yeah which is so
incredible and it was so amazing I cried
and she was like you wanna take a
picture I was like I'm kidding me and it
was funny because she had these two mic
stands or really bedazzled they were
really really cool on his red when he
was white and she was just like let's do
a picture like on the stage and I didn't
think about it but did we both stood in
front of the mic stands and I was like
it looks like we're doing a show
together pose or not so then she posted
it which was like dope but then everyone
was like before me but we're not I just
didn't think about it okay that would be
my dream I don't but I really only want
what she wants like she if she want to
do great play if she don't then I'm fine
five things we don't know about you
people you were in a children's choir
I'm us what did you learn from that um
probably the main thing was how not to
ruin my voice just like learning how to
protect her was and and sing correctly
not like if there's a correct way this
thing but correctly actual
you know like actually make your throat
not tear up like some people when you
hit number one how did you celebrate I
was in Prague and I went to him I was in
I was at a meeting and I thought that
there were really tiny grapes but they
were not grapes they just were really
tiny fruit and they tasted horrible and
then one fell and I sat on it in my
white pants and then I had a big red
stain on my pants that's all that that
day was sorry that's kind of
disappointing no it's not
everyone was congratulating me I was
like why huh and then I looked and it
was like oh number one and it was like
it was a it's actually a huge deal so
I'm really grateful for it but I had no
clue you've got a stay grounded um last
thing do you have any hidden talents we
all know that you can perform to crowds
of huge people make this great music all
that voice but like what is the thing
are you knitting cross I to che yes I do
crochet I love a crochet like a nice
tour bus yeah when I was actually funny
I I loved last tour like the like third
day we were on the bus because I was
still jet-lagged we just got in there we
had this like just this long drive to
get somewhere and I woke up super early
just cuz I jetlag and I was just awake
well and it was like raining outside and
I have my yarn you know I have my lug
crochet thing my crochet needle I opened
I like open the curtains and I just
watched us like drive to where we were
and it was right raining and I played
some Bruno major and some Eloise and I
just crocheted a snowflake